John there's a lot of people there's
been a spike during the corona shutdown
on will preparation mmm people buying
wheels yeah and I'm trying to figure out
in my head if it's because they had time
on their hands or they were scared yes I
think there was probably some space
people get some stuff done because they
you know think about if you were driving
to and from work every day suddenly you
the thirty minutes this way and thirty
minutes that we got an extra hour in
your day so I think people at some time
but I do think this idea especially at
the beginning of this when there was
going to be several million people pass
away you had this idea of where does my
money go who takes care of this stuff
and the unfortunate thing is we've seen
a spike in them but I've also seen on
the back end on the mental health side
folks not being able to go to funerals
and folks dying relatively suddenly and
they don't know what to do they didn't
have a will
yeah you've you've again we talked about
this the other day you've my buddy John
says the only reason to not have a will
is if you hate your wife and kids that's
the only reason to not have one and I
think people really struggle with this
idea this spoiler alert none of us get
out of this alive right and I think it's
so hard for people to look in the mirror
and say one day I'm not going to be here
yeah and the beauty thing of a will of
this momma bear situation is so great is
you get to play a part when you're gone
and helping the people that you love
it's something you can do right now but
man that's a hard psychological leap for
so many people well some people get so
twisted up I've actually heard people
saying this is it's always humorous to
me but I don't want oh well my my die
you know they actually say that you're
gonna help you with this we did research
that is the only research we can we can
listen to these days as if as if doing
the wheel hastens your death you know
that's it but it's almost like but what
that is is they're having to face their
own mortality I mean they're really yeah
and it's hard you have to wrap your head
around somebody else
we taking care of your kids and somebody
else dating your spouse and somebody
else living in your home I mean there's
all kinds of existential things that are
real and heavy but what's those are in
your heart and in your mind what's real
is that you are not gonna be here
someday we spend an inordinate amount of
time on the succession plan here at
Ramsey yeah what's going to happen when
you know when the next generation has
run this place what's going to happen
when you're sitting in this seat I'm not
or Rachel and you were sitting here are
you and Hogan or whatever in name name
there MC personalities is sitting here
right and an inordinate amount of time
oh you know how to run the business when
I'm not here as the CEO and then
inordinate amount of time and there's
all these discussions all the time I
mean my death is discussed so much
around here it's just it's depressing
it's depressing I really thought I told
me cannot discuss this there you go well
when Dave dies you're gonna say when
Dave goes to the lake house just change
this when it goes to play golf it's not
when Dave dies I'm not planning to
retire I'll come around here spread hate
and dissension and do something but when
Dave is not active in the business right
oh my gosh and or in that portion of the
business but it's always when Dave dies
I've been dying for like 15 years now
working on this crap
so in all we're asking to do is to spend
one or two hours to get this done you
want to do 15 years of doctor well and
I'm for 15 years I've gotten used to it
now so yeah I just liked it you call
heaven the lake house that's good call a
lake house heaven that golf course for
me but